i see your id yeah i think i have it
this might be the most famous fake id in
any movie
so famous that someone tried to use it
as a fake id in real life that's why
prop makers have to be extra careful
when making fake ids for movies and tv
shows too good and they could get into
legal trouble we stopped by the hand
prop room in la which made the mclovin
id and the studio of graphic props
artist ross mcdonald to see how
hollywood makes its prop ids
when creating fake ids for production
agencies might limit their customers to
major studios it's the prop maker's job
to make these ids look as real as
possible on screen without crossing into
any legal gray areas like with this new
mexico's driver's license which the hand
prop room made for black widow the photo
of scarlett johansson has been swapped
in for a stock photo and the hologram
which in real ids would be 3d is
actually 2d there's a lot of tricks that
you can use in the graphic itself to
make it look like it's catching light
and having some shine to it for a
special close-up they might simulate the
hologram physically using a silkscreen
and iridescent powders mixed with clear
ink luckily according to graphic props
artist ross mcdonald simplifying
elements like holograms and shadow
images can make the id look better on
screen since it won't be as jammed with
tiny details the rule of thumb is
convincing is better than accurate to
nail the aesthetics prop makers often
focus on the sheen of the id a lot of
the driver's licenses you see especially
now have this kind of map but also a bit
of a sheen look and that's what we're
going to get from the lamination process
laminating will also give it the weight
of an actual driver's license so that
when the actor holds the card it not
only looks but feels like the real deal
for projects that call for close-ups
they use this old school embossing
machine to make sure the lighting
reflects off the numbers on the card in
the right way and for special forms of
id like those for the us army the prop
makers might have to mimic metal chips
for these prop artists can make fake
chips out of vinyl to stick on top of
the id or they can print it on a card
that already has the fake chip built in
but specialized ids pose another problem
they're often very very plain military
id cards police identification even the
fbi identification they're meant to be
looked at really close up but on a tv
screen they might be sort of holding it
up and we're looking at them from eight
feet away as a prop artist you'd maybe
spice things up with a flashy gold badge
or this type of giant fbi logo you see
popping up a lot in shows and movies a
lot of times the frame of reference that
viewers have is other shows the x-files
one is one that you see copied a lot the
id also needs to play well in the scene
f
b
i
like this 1920s one ross made for a
prohibition agent and boardwalk empire
he first produced an id faithful to what
agents carried at the time but after
some rehearsals the filmmakers asked him
to add space for a badge inside so the
agents would have something to flash
things get tricky when it comes to
passports which are generally much
harder to forge than id cards because of
all the detail involved across multiple
pages to make a current us passport the
hand prop room has to print and trim the
pages do a clear overlay on the photo
page and silk screen the cover to give
it that authentic sheen
after sewing the pages together the prop
makers assemble the passport and do a
final trim
to avoid legal troubles prop houses will
sometimes deliberately alter the look
like on this netherlands passport for
madame secretary the show's legal team
asked the hand prop room to make the
passport less accurate by reshuffling
the layout and changing the color scheme
with historical ids legality isn't an
issue so prop artists can get a lot more
authentic on period shows that's what
ross did when he made this 1920s
passport for steve buscemi's character
on boardwalk empire passport
ross first had to track down a 1921
passport to use as a model then
digitally clear out the existing info
and recreate the background pattern so
that he could go in and write the new
material on top he had to find the red
legal seal in europe since the u.s
doesn't use that kind anymore then
emboss the seal and photo make print and
perforate the stick on stamps and
recreate all the rubber stamps to match
those of the time period he was lucky to
have an example to work with it can be a
lot harder to find reference material
for more mundane forms of id like a
driver's license from a specific year
and state especially from
pre-1980 there's no reason for anyone to
digitize that for this one the closest
reference ross could find was a photo of
a new jersey license from 1923.
he scanned it and built all this type on
top of it in the computer to recreate a
high-res version since this stuff is so
hard to find ross keeps folders of all
the reference materials he's compiled
through the hundred plus movies he's
worked on when he's working off a
pixelated photo like this one the
hardest part is recreating the actual
document part of the id ross has to
identify all the typeface so he places
different fonts over the original text
to find ones that match
it helps to have a library of antique
fonts used in different time periods you
can date this particular cutting of this
font to between 1815 and roughly 1825.
sometimes though you have to recreate a
whole alphabet for this 1960 passport
made for an unreleased project jacob
scanned six or seven real passports from
the era to capture every letter of the
alphabet then cleaned up the letters and
vectorized them to make a whole new font
just for this particular year of
passports his team also had to recreate
by hand the blue to red effect of this
special 60s stamp replicating the look
of old printing tools takes some
creative problem solving the hand prop
room used printing tricks on the 67
california license for chris pine's
character and i am the knight to make
the text look like it came out of a
typewriter
whenever possible it helps to use the
real deal ross prints all kinds of seals
and typefaces on his old school
letterpress which is operated by a foot
pedal
then there's the question of what to
write ross made these illinois licenses
for a scene where the police raid a
packed speakeasy which meant a bunch of
background characters needed to show id
so ross had to make up a bunch of names
addresses exact heights weights and more
after about the tenth one you're like
did i use john smith already ross will
often refer to period yearbooks for
names that sound old school this guy's
aloysius so wiki and for main characters
all this info needs to be confirmed with
production these are passport
instructions for owen sleeder in
boardwalk empire providing details like
the character's full name and hair color
but leaving out other pertinent
information a lot of other documentation
requires things like birth dates they
you know the writers have never even
considered how old the character is or
what his birthday is at the end of the
day though graphic prop artists like
ross and jacob don't always know how the
prop will be used when they're creating
it sometimes these props are highlighted
in the action but sometimes you're doing
a lot of research and work for an id
that may only be flashed on screen for a
split second so incredibly elaborate
prop which we
see in the episode
like this he just hands it across the
counter
there were no pictures of the criminal's
unwanted posters in the 19th century
it's something that comes from the
movies most people didn't have
photographs of themselves